good evening good evening welcome staff
students alumni and Friends of Hillsdale
College my name is Alex Nestor I'm a
sophomore here studying economics and
journalism and tonight I have the honor
of introducing our speaker dr. Daniel J
Mahoney is the Augustan professor and
distinguished scholarship at Assumption
College he earned his BA at the College
of the Holy Cross and his MA and PhD at
Catholic University of America dr.
Mahoney has written for numerous
publications including first things the
Claremont Review of Books in The Wall
Street Journal
he is the book review editor of society
in the executive editor of perspectives
and political science he is the author
of numerous books including Alexander
Solzhenitsyn the ascent from ideology
the conservative foundations of the
liberal order and the other Solzhenitsyn
telling the truth about a misunderstood
writer and thinker he is the co-editor
with Edward e Erickson of the
Solzhenitsyn reader new and essential
writings please help me in giving a warm
welcome to dr. Daniel J Mahoney
she was worried about pronouncing
Solzhenitsyn but she did very well by
the way if I had a little more time
Solzhenitsyn had a very rich life he was
born December 11th 1918 next year
December 11 2018 will be his centenary
this is death centenary of his birth and
I would give you a little biographical
account of Solzhenitsyn but it would
take about 20 minutes and we don't have
20 minutes so I will try to do my best
to fill in some details along the way my
talk is entitled judging communism and
all its works Solzhenitsyn's the Gulag
Archipelago reconsidered and i'm going
to begin by quoting a very famous
passage early on in book 1 of the Gulag
Archipelago a chapter called the Blue
Caps Macbeth self justifications were
feeble and his conscience devoured him
yes even Iago was a little lamb to the
imagination and the spiritual strength
of Shakespeare's villains stopped short
at a dozen corpses because they had no
ideology ideology that is what gives
villainy it's long sought justification
and gives the villain the necessary
steadfastness and determination thanks
to etiology the 20th century was faded
to experienced villainy on a scale
calculated in the millions Alexander
Solzhenitsyn writings remain the great
scourge of the ideological justification
of tyranny and terror the amplification
of violence in the 20th century and the
sole numbing mendacity that accompanied
it cannot be blamed on purely accidental
or contingent considerations nor can it
be explained away is a mere product of
the rush
in tradition that's what they do over
there or the residues of an Asiatic
despotism alien to modernity and modern
progress truth be told the ideological
justification of utopia and power is
part and parcel of philosophical and
political modernity rooted in the
unfounded belief that human nature and
society can be transformed at a stroke
the allure of a revolution that
inaugurates a radically new human
dispensation of progress that leaves
Yuman nature behind in its wake our
illusions at the heart of what Erich
vogelin aptly called modernity without
restraint the ideological justification
of evil haunts modernity and modern
progress and I insist they are not
distinctively Russian phenomena in
opposition to them Solzhenitsyn appealed
to basic verities such as an unchanging
human nature and an order of grace that
is capable of elevating human souls that
are also capable of great evil
Solzhenitsyn's critiqued of ideological
despotism of the Soviet or Maoist sort
or Nazi sword for that matter is at the
service of a more fundamental
reaffirmation of the drama of good and
evil in the human soul shorn of every
utopian illusion his work finally points
toward catharsis and spiritual ascent
there is not a trace of niall ism or
despair to be found in his writings
light is ontologically prior to darkness
just despite the persistence of evil in
the human soul
the contrast between Solzhenitsyn's
Gulag Archipelago and varlam shala moves
Colima tails with its dark and
unmitigated view of human nature could
not be more striking that's the other
great gulag work and shallow mouths
conclusion was the fundamental truth
about the human condition supports Aniel
ism the man is a beast a man that there
is no enduring truth there is no light
there is no catharsis central to
Solzhenitsyn's moral and political
vision is the non-negotiable distinction
between truth and falsehood
Solzhenitsyn's target was precisely the
ideological lie that presented evildoing
as a necessary historically necessary
stage in the faded progress of the human
race he always insisted that the
ideological lie was worse than violence
and physical brutality ultimen
ultimately more destructive of the
integrity of the human soul after
returning to Russia in May 1994 after 20
years of involuntary exile in the West
18 of those years spent in Cavendish
Vermont he never wavered in telling the
truth about communist totalitarianism
and the lies that undergirded as he
never tired of pointing out the only way
forward was through repentance and
telling the full truth about communism
and all its works during a talk at the
University of Saratov on September 13
1995 this is when Solzhenitsyn is
already back in post-communist Russia
Solzhenitsyn took aim at those who saw
the Soviet regime as some kind of
paradise pained by how deep illusions
ran and how resonant resilient the lie
still was he made clear that quote
since the middle of the 1920s I have
forgotten nothing end quote
the atmosphere in Lenin's Russia was he
said already full of cruelty to those of
his interlocutors who whitewash Stalin
he bore witness to quote the nightmarish
beginnings of the 1930s when the entire
edifice of the universe seemed ready to
collapse everything we knew of human
rate relations was destroyed that's all
the quotation the best among the
peasants were hurled unto unto wagons
and freezing snow with their young
children receiving no mercy no display
of elementary human decency
such Solzhenitsyn said was the human
meaning of class struggle millions were
killed and deported in what was the
greatest crime of the Soviet regime the
great catastrophe for Solzhenitsyn and
that was the the killing of the
independent peasantry many of the
victims of the great terror of 1937 the
people Arthur Kessler writes a back
about were morally sullied in soul
genesis view by their participation and
previous waves of terror and
collectivization against so-called
enemies of the people
some of Solzhenitsyn's interlocutors
talking about 1994-1995 blame the
destruction of the independent peasantry
the flower of the russian nation and the
ukrainian nature and I should add on the
impending war however association
remained unimpressed by this
transparently mendacious argument but
what if after the war he asks he told
almost every group he met in those years
about a secret decree promulgated by
Stalin in 1948 that sentenced those on
the caucuses the collective farms who
failed to live up to impossible work
norms almost all were women
since man had largely left the
collective farms to deportation to
Siberia
no one had heard of this absolutely no
one
Solzhenitsyn had published this
notorious degree in 1993 in his
collection the peasantry in the state
and the book series research on modern
Russian history
such was Solzhenitsyn retort to those
who saw nothing but unadulterated
progress in the 70 year experience of
Soviet ISM and I quote Solzhenitsyn ah
the paradise that was extraordinary when
here Solzhenitsyn's voice in its
sardonic mode well-known to readers of
the Gulag Archipelago a tried and true
way of piercing through the veil of
ideological mendacity
in the three volumes of the Gulag
Archipelago which appeared in the west
between 1973 and 1976 or so although
largely written in utmost secrecy in the
winters of 1965 and 1966 Solzhenitsyn
wrote them in the wrote the gulag in the
forests of Estonia that's another story
Solzhenitsyn had already slain the
dragon of ideologies he did so with the
rhetorical gifts of a world-class writer
he had sifted through the accumulated
experiences of 256 collaborators
witnesses to the Soviet camps who had
sent him narratives letters memoirs and
other eyewitness accounts of applied
ideology at work he of course also drew
widely on his own first-hand experience
of prison camp and exile in the Soviet
Union
beginning with the 2007 Russian edition
of The Gulag Archipelago
Solzhenitsyn provided a complete
list of these hitherto invisible allies
who made the writing of the Gulag
Archipelago possible in this work he
draws widely on their experiences so
much so that the book has been
characterized by the russian as john b
dunlop as a person allistic feast since
it gives human form to the millions of
souls who were unjustly imprisoned or
killed by the Bolsheviks in a crucial
chapter in the third volume poetry under
a tombstone truth under a stone
Solzhenitsyn observes how in prison
quote all our depersonalized with
identical haircuts identical fuzz on
their cheeks identical caps identical
padded jackets he adds that quote the
the face presents an image of the soul
distorted by wind and Sun and dirt and
heavy toil unquote the task of the
philosophical poet is that of quote
discerning the light of the soul beneath
the depersonalized integrated exterior
unquote of human beings and the camps
but but Solzhenitsyn calls the sparks of
the Spirit have a power of their own
that literature alone can truly
incarnate the Gulag Archipelago is what
Solzhenitsyn called in its subtitle an
experiment in literary investigation in
no sports no small part because of its
power to illuminate the sparks of the
Spirit that miraculously survived the
assaults of ideology human nature is
more powerful than ideology God's grace
is more powerful than imperfect human
nature the Gulag Archipelago will be
best remembered through to deathly
prepared abridgements of that great work
the first was prepared by my
collaborator professor Edward Erickson
in collaboration with Solzhenitsyn it
was published in the United States
Canada and the United Kingdom in 1985
the first abridgement coming in at 472
pages about a third of the original did
justice to the essentials of the work
and most importantly gave equal space to
the elements of light and catharsis that
were evident in the latter half of the
work in other words a lot of people had
this initial experience of picking up
the Gulag Archipelago reading accounts
of oppression of the human being being
degraded and putting it down after a
hundred pages they never got to those
sections of the book that show the
endurance of the human spirit or the
resistance to evil or the capacity of
some such as Solzhenitsyn to truly stand
up to evil since 2007 that edition the
American and English abridgement has
been introduced by the journalist and
historian and Applebaum in 2003 she
published Bulaga history an excellent
work indebted to both Solzhenitsyn and
archival research the second abridgement
prepared by natalia Solzhenitsyn
Solzhenitsyn's Widow and published in
Russia in 2010 for use in Russian high
schools is equally well done it comes in
at five hundred and ten pages in the
Russian Edition here it is archipelago
logged and at eight hundred ninety nine
pages in the French translation of the
two
an antenna Bridgman that the integrity
of the hole is scrupulously respected as
are the special needs and interests of a
Russian readership thus abridgement has
been available in French since 2014
along with Natalia Solzhenitsyn's
bracing introduction to the work
suggestively entitled the gift of
incarnation english-language versions of
mrs. Olsen's Anita's essays have also
appeared in the New Criterion in
September 2012 and as an appendix to my
own 2014 book the other Solzhenitsyn
telling the truth about a misunderstood
writer and thinker thinker drawn on
Natalia Solzhenitsyn's wonderfully
insightful introduction to the Gulag
Archipelago I will highlight features of
the work that get to the heart of its
enduring achievement as the taya
Solzhenitsyn notes Solzhenitsyn expertly
tells the story of what he calls the
history of our meeting the Soviet sewage
disposal system his name for the Soviet
system of repression this system was
fueled by Lenin's decrees and by
Stalin's edicts which tried precisely to
efface the sparks of the spirit about
which we have spoken note the reference
to Lenin Solzhenitsyn rightly insists
that Lenin is the initial architect of
Soviet terror and totalitarianism it was
Lenin who spoke in his essay how to
organize the competition written on
January 7th and 10th 1918 about the
great ideological task of quote purging
the Russian land of all kinds of harmful
insects
Solzhenitsyn cites this essay early in
Volume one of the Gulag Archipelago
these insects and notice the rhetorical
dehumanization of so-called enemies of
the people that precedes their actual
imprisonment or execution
they included workers malingering at
work people in the self-governing Zim's
folk councils left over from the Zoras
period nuns priests monks members of
cooperatives suspect teachers eccentric
Tolstoy ins and those of bourgeois class
origin the number and kinds of incense
to be purged would expand considerably
under Stalin in the 1930s kulaks and by
the way to be a Kulak you simply had to
have two pigs in a cow it was the
principle of ownership that made you a
Kulak kulaks the most intelligent and
industrious peasants became the dreaded
class enemies and 85,000 priests and
nuns were executed in 1937 alone and
terror soon turned against the source of
terror itself with the purges and the
show trials in Moscow and elsewhere
against loyal communists it really is
true Solzhenitsyn does not have a great
deal of sympathy for the men of 37
because they were complicit in the
previous waves of repression in the
organization of the competition against
so-called enemies of the people
mrs. Solzhenitsyn argues none of this
was a matter as Khrushchev put it in
1956 of violations of socialist legality
but instead it was the inevitable
outcome of the system itself the system
was what the great Martin Mallia called
in the Soviet tragedy an idio Craddock
part aa cracy a monopolistic rule of a
party more an active conspiracy than a
political party in the Western sense
defined by the ideological justification
of its own tyranny Solzhenitsyn unmasked
the fictive claim that Leninism and
Stalinism could be finally separated
putting the lie to those efforts that
tried to save the purported honor of the
Revolution of 1917 and it's animating
ideology the system was inseparably
Leninist
and Stalinist indeed as logic Kowalski
like to say Stalinism is one possible
and perfectly legitimate interpretation
and appropriation of Lenin's legacy the
remarkable opening sentence of volume 2
of the Gulag Archipelago makes this
eminently clear you got to listen
closely rosy-fingered yose so often
mentioned in homer and called aurora by
the Romans
caressed - with those fingers the first
early morning of the archipelago as
Solzhenitsyn demonstrates with force and
clarity the first camps on the so
Levitsky islands and elsewhere often
perversely enough in Orthodox
monasteries took form under Lenin's
direction in other words
and I quote Solzhenitsyn again the
archipelago was born with the shots of
the cruiser Aurora Dawn from the very
first moment of the Bolshevik Revolution
tyranny coercion totalitarianism and the
camp's were integral to that particular
system ideological justification of
terror and tyranny began with Lenin as
did the Gulag Archipelago
the abit with is system of forced labor
camps itself stalin built on Lenin's
work much as collectivization built on
the war communism of an earlier period
and even replicated its terror famines
mrs. Solzhenitsyn also makes clear that
the gulag archipelago is much more than
a historical treatise or even a great
Homeric work of literature telling the
simplest the story of the imperiled
Zechs as the prisoners were called this
remarkably capacious book includes
historical discussions personal
reminiscences of Solzhenitsyn's time in
the camps political reflections and
philosophical meditations see in
particular the second central section
four of seven the soul and barbed wire
it is she suggestively adds quote an
amalgam combining each of these genres
with the resultant product being more
significant than the sum of its
constituent parts at its heart she finds
an epic poem one that recovers the great
and enduring drama between good and evil
in the human soul Solzhenitsyn is
rightly being compared by Alan Besson
song to st. George
fearless lease abdui the dragon of
ideologies this image conveys a central
dimension of the work but mrs.
Solzhenitsyn also quotes that central
line in gulag one where Solzhenitsyn
tells readers who expect his book to be
a mere political expose to quote slam it
shut right now
Solzhenitsyn is no counter ideologist I
quote a very famous line from the
beginning of the book the line dividing
good from evil runs through the heart of
every human being and never remain
static in any heart or soul one must not
fight communism in the spirit of a
counter ideological mannequin ISM all of
us must struggle with evil Solzhenitsyn
calls on us to avoid the twin extremes
of moral relativism which he considered
to be the bane of our age and
self-righteousness and ideological
fanaticism no one can deny that the
Gulag Archipelago is the most powerful
anti totalitarian book ever written it
is political in the most noble and
dignified sense of the of that term but
ultimately and again I quote Natalia
Solzhenitsyn the book is about the
ascent of the human spirit and its
struggle with evil that is the reason
why when we ders reach the end of the
work they feel not only pain and anger
but an upsurge of strength and light
every reader of the Gulag Archipelago
must come to terms with the luminous
chapter on the ascent where Solzhenitsyn
powerfully discusses his own spiritual
ascent for
the world of the lie and also I should
add his recovery of his Christian faith
and the gripping account of the forty
dears days at can gear were 8000
revolting prisoners politicals and
criminals alike this was in the spring
of 1954 a year after Joseph Stalin's
death put a desire for truth and justice
above the concern for self-preservation
both are available in the two excellent
abridgements under discussion in these
chapters centered respectively on the
recovery of self-knowledge about good
and evil in the human soul and what we
might call the spirited love of Liberty
Solzhenitsyn demonstrates that
totalitarianism never truly succeeded in
subjugating the human spirit
this gives every reader ample and
reasonable grounds for hope natalya
Solzhenitsyn notes that ashore mark that
Russia has changed is that the Gulag
Archipelago is now widely available in
that country
Solzhenitsyn could return home in may
1994 and he could publish freely until
his death on August 3rd 2008 many though
not all documents from the Soviet period
have been Declassified these documents
confirm the essential insights of
Solzhenitsyn's great work to support
this claim
mrs. Solzhenitsyn cites the impressive
forward that Anne Applebaum wrote to the
2007 seven Harper Perennial modern
classics RIA ditions of the Gulag
Archipelago they they reissued each
individual work three plus the
authorized abridgement
Applebaum acknowledges quote that
various errors and Solzhenitsyn works
work have come to light but Apple BEM
emphasizes quote just how much he gets
right despite having no access to
archival documents and government
records his general outline of the
history of the gulag
has proved incorrect his description of
the moral issues faced by the prisoners
has never been disputed his sociology of
camp life is unquestionably accurate
unquote above all Applebaum emphasizes
the Gulag Archipelago z' truthfulness a
commitment to convey the truth about the
clamps that in her words quote continues
to give the book a freshness and an
importance that will never be challenged
unquote the archives tell an important
part of the story about Soviet
repression but there can be archival
fetish nasaan the part of social
scientists and historians the archives
cannot begin to convey the full truth
about the souls encounter with barbed
wire or the human meaning of a regime
dedicated as the Soviet regime was to
the twin pillars of violence and lies in
an important note appended to the first
chapter of volume 2 of the Gulag
Archipelago the finger of Aurora Natalya
Solzhenitsyn pays tribute to the
seven-volume
history of the Stalinist gulag published
by the Moscow publisher Rossman in 2004
and 2005 prefaced by Solzhenitsyn and
Robert conquest this work shows
precisely what the official documents
revealed about the camps and I should
add during the Stalin period not the 20s
not so lucky
not the Lenin period really beginning
with 29 or so or 3,800 to 800,000 people
shot 20 million people pass through
camps colonies of prisons during this
period special populations kulaks and
deported peoples constituted another 6
million people over 5 million people
were detained in camps or special villa
villages under the surveillance of the
mvd MVD at the time of Stalin's death in
March 53 but these statistics do not
begin to tell us the full truth about
the extent of Soviet repression after
1917 as Oleg Revenue documents and very
important book
Stalin new biography of a dictator
published by Yale University Press in
2015 8 million people died in the
russian civil war 5 million people died
in a famine largely caused by Lenin's
draconian policy of war communism
talking about the late teens and early
20s not talking about the famine of 30s
whole peoples like the Don Cossacks were
subjected to what only be called
genocide half of the Don Cossacks died
in nineteen twenty twenty-one twenty-two
at least five to seven million peasants
perished in southern Russia the North
Caucasus in the Ukraine in 1932 and 1933
mainly Ukrainian but many Russians and
and also a third of the people of
Kazakhstan perished during that period
and during the Great Patriotic War
millions perished or were punished for
retreating from the advancing German
army clevon iakh writes that on average
over the more than 20
year span of Stalin's rule 1 million
people were shot in course incarcerated
or deported to barely hospitable areas
of the Soviet Union every year now I
should and one doesn't turn to the Gulag
Archipelago cappella go for precise
numbers regarding the number of people
killed or imprisoned during Lenin his
Stalin's rules aneesa's estimates were
that just that estimates they're a
little bit on the high side and as for
the total loss of life under lenin and
stalin conservative estimates from
nicholas Nicola Nicola Verret and the
black book of communism go from 20
million Alexander Yakovlev who was in
charge of the Presidential Commission on
repression under Lenin and Stalin during
both the Yeltsin and Putin years
estimates of estimates about 35 million
victims of political repression and
government instigated famine
nevertheless Solzhenitsyn rightly
captures that this was a calamity of the
first order with millions even tens of
millions perishing at the hands of an
ideological despotism he dramatically
chronicles what applied ideology can do
to both the bodies and souls of human
beings the latter point is crucial as
the great chapter of volume 2 of our vom
- of gulag are muzzled freedom to read
nothing else read our muzzled freedom
Solzhenitsyn is also interested in
chronicling the lie and betrayal as
forms of existence he's talking about
free Soviet life Soviet Communism was a
calamity for the living as well as the
dead this quote comes from 1998 from
Solzhenitsyn with their reverse
selection their deliberate destruction
of all that was bright
remarkable of a higher level the
bolshevik set about changing the Russian
character root and branch lost my place
ripping pulling and twisting it this led
to what Solzhenitsyn calls a meltdown of
the people's morals a meltdown whose
consequences the ex-soviet people's are
still dealing with betrayal of friends
co-workers and family were a Vic WA tiss
lying became a way of life again
Solzhenitsyn it was unavoidable if you
want to survive lie lie in pretend in
place of all the good that was dying
away ingratitude cruelty and thoroughly
rude self-centered ambition now rose and
established themselves Solzhenitsyn
makes clear that systemic mendacity the
lie the ideological line would survive
the Stalin period with the lie and
small-minded concerns for
self-preservation at the center even of
post Stalin Soviet life as Solzhenitsyn
told Yanis a Fiats of the BBC in an
interview in January 1979 it would take
a very long time indeed for Russia to
fully recuperate from such a physical
and spiritual calamity what was needed
Solzhenitsyn said was inner development
not imperial expansion the disastrous
way in which Russia came out from under
the rubble of communism in the 1990s
with massive corruption and kleptocracy
under Yeltsin only made matters worse as
Solzhenitsyn makes clear in his 1998
book Russia in collapse and I'm just
about nearing the end
the 2010 abridgement of the Gulag
Archipelago is still widely taught in
russian high schools in fact it is
regarded as mandatory or required
reading natalia dmitrievna Solzhenitsyn
ah regularly meets with teachers about
how to approach the work teacher
resources about how to teach the Gulag
Archipelago are readily available on the
Russian internet the present regime and
that means the President Putin and the
Prime Minister Dmitry Medvedev supports
the inclusion of gulag in the curriculum
though some communists and super
Patriots in the Putin camp only want
good things said about Russia and no
nasty things as the author son Stefan
Solzhenitsyn recently told me quote such
people frequently called for gulag to be
ousted from the curriculum attack
Solzhenitsyn claiming he made it all up
or that he was the West Point's and to
destroy our super power and attack
Natalia Dmitrievna - forgetting the book
into the school curriculum Stefan
Solzhenitsyn added that quote they have
not prevailed and we hope they will not
prevail the continuing presence of
Solzhenitsyn's gulag in Russian schools
along with one day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich and Solzhenitsyn's great
short story met Rihanna's home they're
all required high school reading is a
sign of hope
October 30th 2017 we'll see the opening
of Russia's memorial to the victims of
political repression under communism
cofán co-founder funded by the
government and donations from civil
society the Solzhenitsyn told me the one
thing that couldn't be done was foreign
money the regime would look very askance
on that but this major monument to the
victims of 70 years of Communists
oppression will be dedicated in Moscow
on the 30 of October these two were
facts about Putin's Russia and signs
that Lenin is Stalinism is not simply
the subject of nostalgia or apologetics
in contemporary Russia
Solzhenitsyn is still a force for truth
in the Russia he loves so much the
availability of the gulag provides hope
that the terrible tragedies of the past
will not be repeated and that the
remnants of the ideological lie will not
go uncontested in post-communist Russia
and in the West the gulag archipelago
remains in indispensible warning against
the ideological deformation of reality
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You dr. Mahoney we now have time
for a few questions if you would raise
your hand a microphone will be brought
to you can you hear me uh in view of
what we know okay okay over there in
view of what we know about what was
going on during that period why do you
think the left continues to admire those
periods of time in Russia and those
parts of the world why did why are they
so successful in lifting that up as an
ideology to be followed I think modern
democracy is complicit in the ideology
of of progress
we to accept a softer version of the
claim that some kind of not change in
human nature but some kind of
fundamental transformation of the human
condition is possible and so I think a
lot of people on the left in particular
wanted to believe that while the methods
of Soviet Communism might in some way be
questionable they shared the broad
aspirations of enlightenment and
democracy Harry Hopkins Roosevelt's
principal aide famously called the
Soviet Union the New Deal in a hurry
which is not I think fair to the New
Deal but it's but but in any case this
you know it's much easier for a Western
intellectual to be sympathetic to
Bolshevism or communism or Castro ism or
maoism because they can see it as a more
complete and revolutionary manifestation
of the ideals of enlightenment the
Nazism on the other hand entailed the
kind of brutal rejection of democratic
principles and of the philosophy of the
of the Enlightenment so I think that's
part of it on this subject
read chapter 59 of in the first circle
it's the story of mrs. Roosevelt's visit
to the gulag in 1944 and mrs. mrs.
Roosevelt was not a communist but I
think it's fair to say that she and the
man who almost became president of the
United States except he was kicked off
the ticket in 1954 44 Henry Wallace and
ran as a pro communist Progressive Party
candidate in 1948 they both went to the
Soviet camps and liked what they saw
they were impressed by the progressive
methods on hand
Solzhenitsyn describes prisoners who
hair was cut or given the clothes that
were rid of lice who were handed Bibles
and town woods and Correns
and there's a statue of Buddha smiling
in the corner and at the end of the
chapter one time a prisoner has the
courage to go up to mrs. Roosevelt and
say you know these are death camps where
you know we're being destroyed body and
soul she asked the translator what's
being said he says he's protesting the
killing of Negroes in Alabama No
so at the end of this chapter all the
paraphernalia is taken away there put it
back in crowded circumstances the food
is taken away the Bibles are taken away
and there's just an enigmatic statue of
a smiling Buddha in the corner looking
down on this whole Potemkin village and
ideological Shohreh first circle ends
there's a reporter for the French
leftist progressive paper Liberace all
those of you know a little intellectual
history might know in jean-paul sartre
after a triumphant visit to the Soviet
Union in 1951 came back to Paris and
wrote an article on Liberace on saying
freedom of criticism was totaled in this
the Union and that's why they didn't
need bourgeois things like elections but
anyway the reporter a group of prisoners
are being transported from one prison to
another from a prison to a gulag camp
and this these prisoners are in trucks
that are labeled in four languages meat
and bread and the reporter for Liberace
on reports that there's an ample
provision of bread and meat in the
Soviet capital so Solzhenitsyn was quite
perplexed by the Phenom he despised
jean-paul Sartre if there was any human
being he despised it was Sartre Simone
de Beauvoir and jean-paul Sartre went to
Moscow in 1965 and they wanted to meet
with Solzhenitsyn Solzhenitsyn and his
memoir open the camp says I could not
possibly meet with these two he says and
Simone de Beauvoir wrote in her memoirs
well he obviously didn't understand us
we understood him so much better than he
understood us to which Raymond Rong
retorted in an essay called Sartre and
Solzhenitsyn's Solzhenitsyn understood
jean-paul Sartre just fine you know so
this was a real fun if you wanna you
want to read the definitive account of
intellectual indulgence toward left-wing
totalitarianism it's a 1981 book by the
Hungarian born sociologist he writes for
Rogers magazine the New Criterion Paul
Hollander it's called political pilgrims
and it tells the record the sorry record
of progressive minded intellectuals or
indefatigable apologists for every
communist regime on earth it's quite a
funny story but I think it I think it
really does have something to do with
this desire to believe communism is
simply an amplification or maybe even a
perfection of democratic ideals
I I'm I'm actually a great admirer of
Sultan eaten and he it's not very
obvious that it puts great stress on the
spiritual life in this society and I
think this is my question directly
answered I can't hear you too well
sorry my direction quite directly answer
is direct in this in terms of the answer
to communism yeah
in his Harvard address he he warns of
the West void and morality in terms of
like sexual and morality extremes of
legalism and dangers of a materialistic
society and especially the overall
overreaching power of the media and he
says that he doesn't have he would not
suggest our cultural and political
system as an answer to the Communists
and I actually strongly agree with him
in this what would he say is the
necessary is necessary to bring back the
essential spiritual life in the West and
in Russia and does it mainly have to do
with the idea of suffering that people
like him the you know kind of great
literary authors of like Russia like him
Dostoevsky those who really found the
great essence of the Divine within their
own suffering
I think the Harvard address is pretty
fundamentally misunderstood
Solzhenitsyn began the Harvard address
by saying he speaks as a friend but he
also reminded his listeners at Harvard
that Harvard's motto was Veritas truth
and he's then going to speak some bitter
truth he spoke very admiring ly about
the American founders he said when
Liberty was tied to what he called the
great reserves of mercy and sacrifice in
the West they could do great things he
worried that our liberal principle had
been reduced to a principle of
self-preservation so we worried about
the decline of Spirit in the West but he
always spoke as a friend
um he did as you pointed out criticize
what he saw as excessive legalism he was
it'll be coming out next year
Solzhenitsyn's memoir about his twenty
years in the west between two millstones
he was a pole he felt it easier to deal
with the lies of the communist regime
than by the half-truths and distortions
of the American press the New York Times
The Guardian etc easier to deal with the
KGB than the New York Times give that
some thought so but Solzhenitsyn did
criticize excessive legalism if we
thought the letter of the law was
sufficient to guide a free and dignified
human life but I'll remind you the very
last chapter of the Gulag Archipelago
vol 3 is called there is no law
Solzhenitsyn wrote this in 1967 or 68 he
thought that rule of law was an integral
feature of any decent society and about
suffering there's a beautiful passage in
volume 3 of The Gulag Archipelago where
Solzhenitsyn disagrees with Tolstoy
saying political Liberty is not
important
Tolstoy said that all what matters is
the moral self-development of the
individual and Solzhenitsyn says he
could say that because he lived in a
comparatively liberal Czarist regime he
was left alone to write his books he had
visitors from all over the world but he
said if he lived under what we lived
under in the camps or if his apartment
was blockaded like Akhmatova x' was in
leningrad etc he says he too would have
said political liberty is a necessity
for human beings so we can spiritualize
Solzhenitsyn and he does say many of
those things but there's always a
context even at the end of the Harvard
address Solzhenitsyn says in the Middle
Ages
was an excessive despotic repression of
the body by the soul he says in the
modern post enlightenment era there
tends to be a despotic repression of the
human spirit on materialist grounds and
he says what we need is to go up and
ascent from modernity not back not a
return to some pristine medieval
synthesis but drawing on the
achievements of modern civilization move
forward toward an understanding of human
liberty and dignity that's more
satisfying for the whole human person so
I mean all the quotes who quoted our
legitimate quotations but I
Solzhenitsyn didn't think suffering
could provide the foundation of a
political program on the other hand I
think he was struck he admired the local
self-government he saw in Switzerland in
New England admired many features of the
West but he also thought that Westerners
a whole or cut off from the cookie daeun
challenges of everyday life and that a
little more suffering a little more
sacrifice if Solzhenitsyn had a
principle it's not exactly a political
principle it's a moral principle it's
what he called voluntary notice
voluntary voluntary self limitation one
of his famous essays is called
repentance and self limitation in the
life of nations so I don't think
Solzhenitsyn thought that there would be
some you know Russia's simply dedicated
to spiritual principles but it but he
did think the decadent late modern
postmodern relativistic West was not
exactly a model for the post communist
world then again in 1994 in Lycia stein
he said Who am I to lecture the West
about its decadence given the free fall
of Russia into criminal kleptocracy so
okay
thank you for speaking tonight my
question if I understand one of your
points correctly regards her argument
that the Gulag Archipelago is arguably
the greatest study of the effects of
totalitarianism you said this was the
case because the work argues that hope
cannot be extinguished in the suffering
that one of the novel's virtues is the
truth on a novel or one of the recounts
is we displays the truthfulness
regarding repression and its
characterization of the implementation
of applied ideology so my question is I
was thinking as I haven't read this work
before what are your thoughts on the
other famous totalitarian work 1984 and
how these are different approaches to
the evil of total tell terrorism thank
you well that's a wonderful question
you know Orwell was originally going to
give a different title to 1984 he was
going to call it the last man in Europe
meaning not last man like Nietzsche the
utterly degraded last man the last man
leave meaning really the last human
being Winston Smith and I think 1984 is
a wonderful book and it's a wonderful
book among other things because it shows
what's at stake in totalitarianism the
system addict denial of the structure of
reality truth and falsehood the whole
question whether 2+2 really equals 4 or
did he go Eagles whatever the party says
so I think it's a powerful book O'Brien
is the Grand Inquisitor of Leninist
totalitarianism a boy on our college
campuses today we see a lot of two
minutes of hate no it's a very powerful
book but I think Orwell was finally too
pessimistic he his famous image he
feared that the boot of despotism could
rest on the human face forever
I think paradoxically salsa dates that
didn't think that was possible that you
may had more confidence in the
restorative powers of human nature but
then again 1984 one of the reasons why
we don't live in a world faced with the
grave evils that or well or Solzhenitsyn
write about is their own witnesses you
know their own witness to truth their
own account of the human spirit but on
that issue I think Orwell comes close if
not to despair to a fear that the human
spirit can be permanently subjugated
that human nature can be transformed in
that sense I would say he ended up
accepting are almost accepting one of
the premises of totalitarianism that
Solzhenitsyn never accepted okay
[Applause]